what is up there reject nation john and
i literally haven't slept at all because
spectrum internet sucks man hawkeye got
up late had to have some phone calls
with that internet company and then just
as we were about to finally wrap up and
go it's eight o'clock in the morning
let's go get some sleep multiverse of
madness trailer drops true story uh this
place is the post-credits scene for no
way home the first time it played this
was an impression of john and i people
who are in the theaters can it test if
you happen to look over at us
the second time in theaters
the third time in theaters
so we've heard this trailer three times
and kind of saw some moments the first
time
let's finally take in this trailer the
way god intended on our computer
computer not on the theaters no sleep at
eight o'clock in the damn morning that's
the way you do it
[Music]
don't guess that spell
it's too dangerous why we tampered with
the stability of space-time
the multi-person
is a concept about which we know
frightening
your desecration of reality
it was the only way
but i never
meant for any
[Music]
make a lot of sense
one dollar
wonder
i knew somewhere later you'd show up
i made mistakes and people were hurt i'm
not here to talk about westview
then what are you here for
i need your help
i need to change my goatee again you
know about the multiverse
it's madness
yes
feels like doctor who
i'm sorry stephen
no you're not i hope you understand
[Music]
so excited for
our universe
oh
[Music]
what's up variant
strange supreme
[Music]
supreme
wow it's so weird to put the images to
the audio ever three times
like i caught i caught the tail end of
strange supreme the image of him in the
theaters of the first time we saw it but
to just see that i was like whoa that's
crazy yeah creepy creepy as hell how
exciting is this yeah it's heavy right
now that this
is the first
movie to come out of the mcu thus far to
uh directly acknowledge the shows like
that's that was what if and then they're
clearly with the events of wanda yeah
well and and that looked at least akin
to the room that kang was in at the end
of loki when he actually meets with
strange supreme ears so oh yeah good
call man good call yeah it looks like
they're finally doing what we've all
been expecting them to do
with all the movies that have come up
until now this must i'm i'm wondering if
this is probably going to be the
freaking movie that factors in the
events of loki and the multiverse
branching off and all that yeah excuse
us if our words are not that strong i
think we've both been awake for more
than 24 hours at this point
since since we've slept
yeah no i mean it's it's funny because
yeah everything that's come since loki
everyone's been like oh man now it's
popping off but they didn't really
mention any of the events of loki and
even like spiderman no way home like
none of that really factors in
explicitly so yeah it'll be exciting and
loki has so much doctor who in its dna
and you pointed out like this feeling
like doctor who and like i love
branching further out mcu style into
that kind of sci-fi getting a little
look at mordo having uh dreads his
awesome looking dreads showcasing he's a
villain this time around right but with
a righteous kind of motivation
i think we're both trying to appear like
we're sharp
but here's sharp here's the fact of the
matter is we're both a little brain dead
right now
i'm talking and i don't know what i'm
saying why a nazi and it was pretty cool
to catch here was this uh schuma
i think this one was called the
technical one yeah or at least i think
we never found out exactly what it was
yeah we never found exactly what it was
but in the episode four of what if the
tentacle monster it seems like it's
really pulling directly from there you
know what i'm also thinking is that
wanda's whole thing in one vision dealt
the whole thing was about grief
and strange supreme his whole thing is
about grief as well
so i'm actually wondering because we've
heard rumors that you know he would have
to fight against wanda directly if some
type of like oh they're forming maybe
perhaps an alliance doctor strange and
strange supreme but then eventually
become enemies as you would one might
expect somehow an alliance would maybe
form with wanda and strange supreme when
they both like they both want to utilize
the powers of time and multiverse
together to absolve themselves of the
pain they feel and grief i'm actually
sounding kind of intelligent right now
if they team up that'd be a crazy ass
team up and imagine more variants we can
get of even more strangers oh dude you
could get gay strange you can get black
strange black strings and play by better
day cumber batch yeah yeah yeah
you get every one of every ethnicity
yeah you know you get one in a halloween
costume or something like that what
we're thinking about is the movie the
one yeah the real one first movie to
explore the multiverse
sloppy yes at one point you see even
christine getting married which doesn't
look like at all that she's gonna get
married to dr strange no man's messed up
and that's the biggest conflict in the
entire movie it's just strange trying to
get to the wedding so he can object then
by the time he gets there he's like you
know what i'm just gonna put her life in
danger so maybe it's better that i just
watched this happen it's pretty crazy
how spider-man no way home had
characters from the sam raimi films of
course kevin feige was
some level of producer on those movies
and now he's coming back here and it's
the fault it's the one the movie after
spider-man no way home there's a bit of
a full circle touch to it all don't you
think yeah wouldn't you agree and then
doctor strange mentioned in spider-man 2
as well yeah names taken names taken and
to be in this position now there's
something kind of beautiful about it you
do get you know some of those horror
flourishes throughout and he
obviously has worked in spectacle as
well sam raimi my my curiosity is more
just did you enjoy making this man
because i can never tell with the big
films anymore so i just hope he enjoyed
making it you got some of the sam raimi
flourishes the more the merrier when you
let sam raimi be a little bit unleashed
especially with the horror realm that'd
be cool i just don't want this to feel
like you slapped on sam raimi's name
essentially made a studio film hence why
the former director left this project
yeah a little bit i mean like i do get
concerned because
sam raimi i feel like maintains arguably
more personality on big blockbuster the
one for them in the one for them one for
me balance yeah i feel like you get
elements of his style but in the more
recent ones it's watered or it's yeah on
the periphery and so the thing i'm very
curious about is you know i feel like
returning to marvel would be sort of a
deliberate choice for him and i just am
looking forward to seeing more of his
touch on these images because this
trailer while it got me really excited
is mostly mcu it's mostly marvel
aesthetic it's mostly that kind of style
that i'm used to seeing i mean and dr
strange already has a lot of fantastical
and unnerving imagery so you know that's
on display here but yeah i i really hope
they let him make at least the style of
the film his own because i think he is
absolutely perfect for this world i'm
hoping that a trailer too can illustrate
that stuff more because you know who's
just re-watching those spider-man movies
i'm like oh yeah there's so much it's
like those are the perfect clash between
yeah this is a big expensive blockbuster
but also it seems like you really got to
hone it and stamp it and you know really
make it your own i just when i thought
we were finally wrapping up the video
that i gotta edit with this remarkably
slow internet you decide to go on a
whole little three-minute tangent there
that i now gotta edit down
to in order to save some space to be
able to get this upload up on time
there's a multiversal version of me that
never speaks
i like to meet that version sometimes
but we're keeping the banter in here
anyway guys yeah let's uh
leave your thoughts down below
try to get some sleep
and um hey
maybe we'll see you tomorrow at some
point bye